good morning believe nation today's
message is hustle over to you Jennifer
Lawrence the interesting thing for me to
talk to you and what makes you so
fascinating is just the talent that you
see on the screen but but at the same
time there is a certain innocence and
yet a certain power and it seems to me
it's it's both artists and also business
thank you but do you believe that yeah
my right that's that works very hard to
make true so thank you that it's boat
that thank you because without gaining
some sort of control over the business I
lose some control over the over creative
which is most important so I want you
control of the business the more you can
give flower to the creative exactly I'll
give wings to the create yeah so I used
to stay out of it I don't care I don't
want I don't need this is my business
you know it is important that my agent
that way agent always says I'm his only
client that nothing free calls him back
as soon as he because it's my business
and I respect my agent said you only
client that calls him back to say me if
I ever miss calling probably the only
iris return emails I return phone calls
because you want to know what the
options there are yes I've worked really
hard to build this and I want to
continue building it and it's my
business my personal business so I don't
understand how people do slack thank you
guys so much for watching the question
of the day today is I'm curious how much
are you guys hustling in your business
right now how much are you hustling
leave in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to young you Lou
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really really means a lot to me
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love and I see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events fest
hey believe nation if you want a little
more hustle motivation
stay tuned for some special bonus clips
I worked for Miss Hughes for about eight
months and I got an a weekend gig in New
York so I would do weekdays at WOL in
Washington and drive up on Fridays after
my shift which would end at 7 o'clock
and I'd be on all weekend long over in
Queens that's where the radio station
was located and then I would drive back
to DC and I would never even stop at my
parents house never had time for friends
because everybody was kind of not
understanding my dream and kind of
laughing at me or something or trying to
you know my friends were like real
immature and stupid and wanting to party
and hang out and I'm on a path and my
parents were very you know who do you
want what is this crazy thing you're
doing called Radio I would sleep in my
Subaru they gave me a Subaru for college
graduation and I I would sleep in my car
at every rest stop between New York and
and Washington DC to block out the noise
of people telling you you can't do it
right I would literally be I'd have a
blanket an alarm clock and a quilt and I
would take a bird bath in the bathroom
I'd be woken up by the man sweeping next
to my Subaru looking at me because I'm
like the crazy
you know girl in the and I had a baby
shade without a baby pull the baby shade
down you know and that was my life for
about two months I was going back and
forth how did you get an agent talk
about some name dropp'd right so I had a
friend that at the time was good friends
with Keenan Ivory Wayans okay and I got
to meet Kenan and we became very good
friends I ended up doing lowdown dirty
shame with oh sure yeah but I didn't
have an agent as peaches right
and I was like you know how am i I was
just going through you know the the list
of agencies and I was like I got to get
an agent and so I literally called this
one agent her name was Nancy Rainford
and I said I'm a really good friend of
Keenen Ivory Wayans but he told me to
call you specifically small agency Oh
Melrose but she had me she had Michael
Rapaport at the time oh yeah Michael
Rapaport at the time so I say he told me
to call you specifically uh-huh you know
so I'm running this whole game and she
was like really she was like well why
don't you come in and see me so I went
in to see her you know and I put on the
jazz hands
she was like you know what I like you
I'm gonna represent you and I'm gonna
tell you she was she was an awesome
agent she was an awesome agent she said
she had Michael Rapaport and I and she
started my career she's heard of Micra
and then she eventually got out of the
business but she was the one that
started my whole career and I got in the
door because of that attitude I was like
he told me you specific there's not one
thing Baltimore taught me it definitely
taught me how to hustle you know people
talk about how you need a vacation or
something I don't have a km from what
and I love my life I feel I'm healthy
thank God and you know I have these
incredible directors that that are
interested in working with me and I'm
gonna jump at that as long as there's
enough time to prep and I feel like I
can add to it you know yeah yeah for
sure has it changed in terms I guess
there's a point where you don't have to
chase quite as hard and you know it
depends on the project I still chase I
wrote an email to a director about six
months ago about a project that I just
felt so connected to and never got a
response that's surprising yeah but you
know you never you know it's yeah you
just think professional courtesy would
be enough to oh I'm not in this
from start to finish it takes about nine
months two sometimes longer sometimes
you know ten months it's roughly a year
between the time that the story is
pitched to the time it gets on the air
takes roughly a year to do it and it's
you know no one has ever figured out a
quicker way to do hand-drawn animation
in primetime and it's all still
hand-drawn it's colored with computers
but every single frame is still done by
hand you know the season is a little
smoother than last season last season
was a little smoother than the one
before so it's it's it gets incremental
easier it's still in many ways a seven
day a week job to get this thing done I
mean it's it's it's virtually impossible
thing to do a prime time animated series
yet somehow there's a bunch of people
that do it I you know it's it's I don't
know how the The Simpsons you know does
it for as long as they they've been
doing it but it's it's a it's a it's
just a very very intense process that
just in many ways gets easier when you
get canceled